esta es una sentencia histórica pues
nunca antes en nueva zelanda se había
emitido una condena a cadena perpetua la
decisión de la corte suprema de justicia
de la ciudad de christchurch ha sido
respaldada por los familiares de las
víctimas y también por los gobiernos del
nueva zelanda y australia en medio de la
lectura de la decisión el juez aseguró
que pronto entrarán este australiano de
29 años no sólo es un asesino sino
también un terrorista que en medio del
proceso judicial no ha mostrado
arrepentimiento ni tampoco empatía hacia
los familiares de las víctimas
recordemos que entre las víctimas no
sólo había hombres y mujeres adultos
sino también ancianos y menores de edad
entre ellos un niño de tan sólo tres
años pronto entraron te pasará entonces
el resto de sus días en la prisión de
máxima seguridad de la ciudad de oakland